seul l'unac
alors c'est une star internationale sai
luna c'est énorme j'adore ce titre à m
oui bien sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu connais en espagnol quels mots tu
connais ans l'espagnol s'est terminée
[Applaudissements]
alors en parlant de la ferme et des
ajustements voilà il ya une jeune fille
qui sont épris avoue isabelle - yb à ce
que voulait le faire aujourd'hui ou
demain comme vous voulez mais je vais
pas tarder à partir pour les globes mois
faisant la faillite c'est bien on fera
demain ou secs moelleux pas demain je me
sens pas d'une heure on le fera demain
il fera demain ma chérie tu étais pas là
je te sens pas en butte à une tenue tu
peux pas de défendre comme ça c'est pas
crédible a fait ressortir à lapins de
[Rires]
chasse à la sauce à l'ail et iloveyou
you are formidable à like you d'ailleurs
parce qu'elle est un peu jeune what is
the all by k laquelle égale à 10 h à 18
h plutôt bon et que l'on à 12-13 sens et
a2 et bien c'est bien
derrière podium
ml est trop sympathie bonjour je vous
adore duflot ni condamner la chanson
originale de l'année avec saab
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
alors que les pions
[Applaudissements]
mais quelles cartes ré on est très
contents non seulement gagner la
victoire en plus tout le monde ne
retient que vous ne la cérémonie je vous
jure il ya eu des essais ceux qui ont
été le plus commenté sur les réseaux
21000 impressions et j'avais les
artistes et je vais vous dire parce que
les 2 c les fous même quand ils viennent
ici rappelle 150 fois pourquoi on veut
dire ouais et si on faisait ça qu'on a
un truc dont on savait des bosseurs va
régner le bien qu'on reste avec nous
mais avec plaisir vous avez d'autres
mais peut-être d'autres trophées aller
chercher des sms et des gens c'est à
dire qu'ils demandent c'est votre vrai
tenue c'est votre vrai tenue
[Applaudissements]
renoir l'envi dans l'histoire mais 1000
$ sur la tête du ghana
non mais c'est pas là c'est pas gallas
dans un cirque la dame sortir du rouge
tout le v10 est toujours en rouge c'est
quoi le paris paris tu viens au zénith
s'il gagne tu viens au 19 mars et 9 mois
par contre si joe hogan
ouais je peux vous appeler n'importe
quel m'emmener dans l'émission aller ok
ok quand tu veux moi je suis chaud allez
on y va
non alors si je gagne vous me faites
vraiment ont donc fait trois quatre
titres dans l'émission mais on kiffe
comme ça alors allez allez ça sert à les
décisions d'un plan d'eau pour gratuit
enchante gratuit en un point
[Rires]
attention un point on n'a pas un point
pas de pierre papier
non là alors c'est très cher face à face
au karpaty pierre les ciseaux y est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hier une feuille de papier vous allez
voir la pierre en fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
lessard